a recent survey by breastcancer.org
reveals that nearly half of people with
the disease face serious Financial
burdens not just for the treatment but
there's a price on their personal and
professional lives too cancer costs are
often unaffordable for many patients
the cost of breast Cancer Care is so
high as founder of breastcancer.org Dr
Marisa Weiss has 20 million clients who
depend on the site for information and
she knows all too well the financial
burden of cancer can be crushing the
cost of the Care can be a major side
effect of treatment almost like another
disease and so if you've had breast
cancer but now you've got this sort of
huge debt that you have to struggle with
the survey asked more than 1400 people
who had cancer in the last decade about
out-of-pocket expenses health insurance
coverage how they manage cost and if it
impacted their professional life
nearly half said their diagnosis and
Care created a significant or
catastrophic burden and 37 said that
they reduced spending on basic
necessities like food and housing
about a third of people use all are part
of their savings to pay for Cancer Care
and 21 actually took fewer pills and
prescribed just to preserve their their
resources and 50 percent felt their
breast cancer diagnosis and treatment
had a negative effect on their career
now on that front experts suggest
talking to your boss being clear about
expectations and perhaps adjusting your
hours can you get other considerations
like
um having flexibility with your hours or
working from home or working on the
weekends or just working when you have
the energy and ability to do your job
plus a letter from your doctor can carry
a lot of weight too
now she also recommends maybe
negotiating with your provider to try
and Shrink some of those costs sometimes
you can get a discounted payment plan
also watch out for billing errors and
ask for virtual visits instead of in
person this way you don't have to miss
so much work or time with your family